he's one of my favorite guests uh i love
everything that he is in and i'm not
just saying that because he's uh on hold
listening to me
uh set up his appearance here phoning
into the rich eisen show in advance of
your honor i saw the first episode of
your honor last night uh and it
premieres
on showtime for the rest of the country
to see sunday
at 10 p.m eastern time the great brian
cranston back here on the show how are
you sir
i'm good rich it's good to talk to you
it is good to talk to you too
um so um what have you seen of your well
i mean how have you
been spending your your quarantine did
you catch the world series you
what are you what are you what are you
doing i guess in your spare time
brian it's been a little crazy year
hasn't it yes it has
uh i my wife and i actually got
covered back in march very early on
we were very fortunate that that our
symptoms were
mild and got through it without
too much difficulty and yeah my heart
goes out to
everyone who's suffering greatly right
um
then we had the you know the shutdown
for all that time
uh sports was strange
it wasn't it still is kind of strange um
my dodgers finally getting to
that pinnacle place after 32 years
uh was certainly i was weeping
uh seeing it come to fruition finally
uh and it's been a good year for la
sports the lakers
dominated uh when they needed to and
uh you know god but it's just
crazy and we need we need some
socializing and some hugs i think our
whole society just needs a good hug well
you know what brian you're you're you're
not wrong
you're spot on right there and you know
watching
that world series this year and seeing
somebody like clayton kershaw
celebrate after all those years and
you know and then all these young
players just finally
uh put it all together with mookie betts
i know a lot of dodger fans
that have been you know wish that they
could have actually been in dodger
stadium
or to see it or maybe had an opportunity
to be one of those
few fans in the state of texas but um
i'm sure
again you said you had tears in your
eyes uh watching that
you know well that's how interesting it
was the
la sports fans didn't get a chance to
see
their lakers or their dodgers in person
to win their championships
uh such a strange thing
but isn't it weird how we started
getting used to
empty stadiums whether it's football
basketball baseball
you you then just hyper focus on the
game well i think the reason why that is
and
i mentioned it last week because you
know on a thanksgiving show i am
mandated as a host of a show like this
one to talk about the sports things i'm
thankful for
um in a segment that um the athletes
performing without the fans as if there
are fans there and it meaning
that much more to them and still putting
it out all on the line
makes me as a sports fan forget about
that there's no fans in the stands
just watching the competition it looked
the same you know what i'm saying
just seeing how much it meant to
everybody you know and then you fast
forward to
last weekend and by the way i have an
announcement to make
i got a call from the denver broncos
they want me to try it
how's your arm how's your arm brian i
mean terrible
they can't be any worse than what they
had
but you know but you bring a certain
savvy to the position though brian right
i mean
you know what i mean you do i try to
bring a certain you know
old-school class
[Laughter]
brian cranston here on the on the rich
eisen show uh so
uh before we get to uh your honor um
i want to thank you for this uh bottle
of dose ombres that i'm holding in my
hand right here
um oh you got it good oh my gosh yeah
i mean um and this is something you and
aaron paul from back in your day
um from uh breaking bad uh you put this
together
and um tell me what i should do with
this how should i
how should i serve it brian i mean it is
so
flexible if you like a little smoky
scotchy drink you can
see uh drink it neat just one or two
fingers
or a rock in there a little
fresh lime squeezed in it's perfect
but it mixes so well i i made a
watermelon drink
the other night fantastic muddled
watermelon with a little lemon a little
squirt of
simple syrup and dos hombres
mezcal especially those hombres is
just it's it's just this amazing
spirit and uh we're doing exceptionally
well with it
and we're growing uh exponentially and
we're very proud of it and happy for uh
drink it in good health and share it i i
think we sent you a couple bottles
yes you did the one i'm holding in case
you do have the manifest
on you um is uh batch dh012
a bottle 2793 you could scratch that off
your manifest
um oh bottle 2793 is one of our best
i would expect thank you 2792
was a little it wasn't quite there but
27.93 that's
fantastic and so uh just a couple of
questions about this
we just saw some photographs associated
with the uh the promotion of it
uh should i drink it um in a double
breasted blazer while holding a bunny
rabbit
um brian you know it
it can't hurt it it might
you know it won't help your street cred
but um with french cuffs too no no those
are regular cuffs okay i'm looking at it
right very nice
it looks like it looks like it goes down
smooth and then um
sorry no go no no and and and
does it does it does it pair well with
los poyos hermanos
those hombres yes it does my friend
uh it's it's fantastic in fact i i was
thinking i got to find a place
just to to make uh to have a taco house
i i want to have a restaurant where i
just serve these amazing
tacos that's all we serve and guacamole
and chips
and these street tacos that just corn
tortillas and you fold them and there's
fish and shrimp and and beef and pork
and chicken
i mean and whatever you want it's not
expensive
and and you couple that with
some great dos hombres yes oh my god
you're in business well if you do open
the taco place brian if you don't mind
me just
spitballing here uh i think the uh the
you should hire somebody in a uh yellow
button-down shirt
uh with glasses who's a a front man and
also a pillar in the community
uh i think that would be a good idea
that would be
that would be the way to go and leaving
us all to wonder what really is working
on behind the scenes
of this taco place no man whenever that
guy shows up
everything turns
terrible but that's when things begin to
get more interesting you know what i'm
saying i'm just
yeah yeah if you're on your couch
you know tell that to walter white
that's not a that's not a good sign
and before you move to your current
project you know i'm a total um
uh fan of of breaking bad and and also
do you watch better call saul just like
the rest of us having no idea
what's going on you have no uh inside
information do you just sit back and
watch it unfold
just like the rest of us exactly exactly
right in fact
you know vince gilligan has become a
good friend of mine and i'm seeing him
again this weekend
um but i tell him when i see him don't
let it slip
don't tell me anything that's going on i
do not want to know
and uh and he he smiles
uh yeah i'm i'm a better call saul fan
i'm i'm
looking forward to their their final
season coming up
um i think they're going to start
shooting in in march so it's going to be
a little while before their premiere
again
okay so when there is a pause in any
conversation with vince
uh can can can can can you think of me
at that very moment and and do you can
you can you bring up about you being
part of that final season can you can
i mean how does it come up how do we how
do we make this happen how do we make
this happen brian
you know i i think fans want that more
than i do
all right okay i'm like i'll tell i was
so satisfied with the conclusion
and what happened to walter white that
it's like oh you know he's dead
let it let it let him rest and then he
pitched me and he said
uh hey brian i i got this idea i'm gonna
continue on with uh
with jesse pinkman and you know what
happens to him and el camino
i said you won't be in it and i and i
said do you want me in it he goes i
really do i have a couple ideas i want
run by i said vince you don't even have
to run the idea by me i'm in you want me
in it i'm in it
and um so we did that under the cloak of
darkness right
nobody knew i was in it nobody knew i
was even in albuquerque
uh for two days i snuck in shot it and
snuck back out
so you wouldn't mention it on the rich
eisen show is basically what you're
saying even if it's already been
discussed it's basically what you're
saying to me brian
that's exactly what i'm saying
well i'll tell you thank you so much
behaviors okay very good i know
um again uh bottle 2793 is going to get
uh cracked open
uh because you know the second to last
episode of better call saul this past
season where
uh you know saul uh jimmy mcgill and
obvi
and uh and ehrman trout are in the
desert was an absolute breaking bad
episode i mean that was
close to the original as as better call
saul has gotten that was incredible
brian yeah
and being the consummate performer that
he is
i told bob i said i hope that was
real urine that you were drinking out
there in the desert
don't tell me that you faked that you
gotta drink
your urine man or you are not a real
actor
and uh what was uh what was his response
brian now he said it was lemonade
okay very good yup that's pulling back
the curtain
uh let's talk about your card
[Laughter]
it's close to the real thing uh as
possible uh let's talk about your honor
um it uh i saw the first episode last
night in advance of it premiering and
um i i i don't know if the word intense
is
even gives it the proper treatment
uh you playing a judge of
uh the highest reputation whose son gets
into some considerable trouble
and then everything ensues from there
i'd love to just give you the floor as
to what
people should expect from this show and
and what um
what drew you to it brian well
it it drew me in with the premise um
my son who was grieving at the loss of
his mom
it was a year anniversary of her passing
and
he's an asthmatic and he's driving away
from where she was killed and he's upset
he can't get a hold of his inhaler and
it fell on the floor
and he gets into an accident and he hits
a kid on
a motorcycle and the kid dies at the
scene and
my son who is trembling and trying to
get
his air himself panics
and he leaves the scene of the accident
well he knows it was a mistake but it's
too late
i get home from my work and i know he's
upset
and he confesses to me what happened and
i said say to him
in all that dread we have to do the
right thing we have to turn you in
or else your soul will forever be
you know stained so he goes
i understand and so we drive him to the
police station i'm about to turn him in
i say wait in the car
let me set this up and i'll come get you
and as hard as that even that would be
to turn your own
son into authority to go through the
system
uh to be tried for uh hit and run
oh while i'm there i
two people who are grieving and their
husband and wife and i find
out from one of the policemen in there
that those are the parents of the boy
who was killed
and my heart goes out to them but i also
notice and recognize the man
he is the notorious gangster
of all of louisiana and
that guy would find my son
and kill him without question in my mind
so i realized at that moment that
impulsive decision making
has to be made and at that moment
i decide i'm not doing this i can't
just let my son become a sitting duck
and i
walk out of the police station my son
thinks oh it's time to go in so he gets
out of the car and i tell him get back
in the car
we're leaving no dad you're right we
should turn to get back in the car and i
tell them what happened and i go
we're leaving so from that moment
my life and his life changes forever
because
i'm a judge i'm i'm very noble and
righteous
and all of a sudden i have to start
thinking like a criminal i have to think
how do i create alibis how do i erase
evidence
how do i dismiss or or get rid of
testimony how can i manipulate the
system
to keep my son safe so there's a
definite
moral compromise being made uh
it is harrowing and compelling all the
way through to the final episode
uh so i hope you watch on showtime
starting this sunday it is amazing brian
and i i gotta and the cast again uh
michael stuhlbarg who plays the
the aforementioned uh gangster fans of
boardwalk empire and fargo will know his
work
isaiah whitlock from the wire his famous
line i'm not
able i think you actually used the word
earlier in this conversation
um he's amazing in it hope davis is in
is is you know in everything and then
obviously you uh when i saw the scene
with you and your son when your son told
you what had happened
uh on the road i i thought of when you
were here
in person a few times ago uh when you
were here as part of your
your um memoir a life in parts that we
still have right here on our set
talking about the scene from breaking
bad where you as walter white watching
jesse pinkman's uh girlfriend played by
kristin ritter pass away
and now that was one of the toughest
scenes you've ever had
to be part of because you know you
obviously thought of your own
uh fatherhood i'm wondering if that came
into play in this scene too i mean it
was
i i my wife and i we watched that scene
we held hands the entire time i mean
like because for the grace i mean
unbelievable
brian truly it's it's a parent's worst
nightmare just to
and it's our number one responsibility
as a parent to protect the life of your
child so if
if you had to make that decision
everyone i've talked to
and i would imagine you would say the
same thing would you rich eisen
if you thought one of your children was
in
mortal danger would you become
a criminal in order to save their life
yeah i and i i mean to answer the
question brian i would i would cook meth
too you know what i mean so
yeah you know it's and that's another
kind of parallel that i i kind of
caught in a way and i'm sure you must
have as well when the script lands on
your desk is
you know you're you have these moments
in your life that's presented right on
your lap that you never saw come in
and how do you react what do you do you
mean how do you handle it what do you do
you know i guess i'm just attracted to
characters
who are really damaged
right and also becoming jewish for the
jokes too brian you know
you know it's sustained our people for
three thousand years
[Applause]
you know what i'm saying uh
it offends me as a comedian it defends
him as a communion right oh my gosh
oh it's great uh brian congrats on uh
another winner uh everyone should check
out um
your honor premiering on showtime on
sunday night at 10 p.m eastern time
always appreciate our chats and cherish
them thank you for the call
looking forward to doing it in person
next time rich absolutely and thanks
again for uh bottle
2793 talent aaron paul the same thing to
scratch uh
batch dh012 off the list
okay perfect enjoy it thanks guys right
back at you thank you that's brian
cranston
four-time emmy award winner check out
your honor on showtime
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here